institute with a postdoc fellow from the
machine learning part manolis latakus
will tell us about beyond worst case
analysis of optimization in the ml era
since it is a midfield meeting uh first
of all yes i have a long name but you
can call me just manolis just to have
the
most important point my name is manoli
nice to meet you
so this is the area that i was working
during my phd
and in order a little bit to give you an
idea another thing that you can learn
about me is that
yeah and i am greek so my story my my
story will start with things in greek so
essential greeks believe that
we lived in the regularity that our
nature is
very regular so everything that they
have in their taxonomy in their
physics was more or less based in
regular shapes that was the reason that
in their physics fire water earth
anything that was the basic item of the
nature was described by volhidra with a
regular polygons now many many centuries
later
a mathematician of combinatorial
geometry called the
normal johnson studied this structure
and he asked a very natural mathematical
question how many different
convex polyhedra you can have with
regular polygons and actually
at
1966
he described the full list
of
the johnson solids as they call it now
he didn't claim that this list is
complete but some years later
a soviet mathematician victor zergler
proved that the list was really complete
now from zartar's proof it holds the
following that the a solid constructed
only by hexagons and petagons cannot be
a convex
body a convex a polyhedron
on the other hand some years ago this
photo
has been taken and you can go and find
it in
in the internet it is called the near
mist
johnson solid and now i can ask you
you can check that it has hexagons and
pentagons as uh construction now the
question is what did we miss given the
zargaler's impossibility theorem
and the the obvious answer is the
impossibilities that we have in the real
world the fact that if i ask you to
accomplish that task to create that
polyhedra you can do it because why
because when you will take the scissors
you will never achieve to have exactly
equal
corners equal measure in the lines now
what is all that connected with computer
science
uh what the what is the software morale
here that the impact of the
impossibility results that
we have plenty of them in computer
science and especially in theoretical
computer science
the impact of the impossibility results
in the real world is strongly connected
about how much robust
they are
in the presence of noise and if there is
an important thing that they understood
during my phd is the following if
someone would like to have a
mathematical theory
for computer science for example that
would explain the real world
what really you need is the following
you would like a perfect model that
describes the imperfection of our world
why because our world is cursed by
imperfections
uncertainty and stochasticity and this
is
if someone would like to ask me what is
i'm interested about any interesting
mathematical problem but to make it a
little bit more
less broad my answer is the following
what i am really keen on working is the
following
if you check out
the previous century is full of results
that says that any ai task that we are
solving right now
is somehow computational heart
however right now we have
similar algorithms that accomplish
tasks that they are important
in our life so my question in my
research is the following why do simple
algorithms work so well even in these
challenging settings if you want a very
simple example for me the most important
example is clustering
almost every interesting representation
of clustering in tcs is empty hard while
clustering is the easiest problem that
we teach in a first
year
ml course so
anything that i will discuss today more
or less will be in the most important
classes that we have the class of np
where we're asking if there is a problem
if there is a solution in our problem
and if we can
check that in a polynomial time and f
and p that is the class where we are
trying to find uh the actual solution
now the classes the the subclass of the
problems that i am really interested in
is the
intersection of them that it is called
tflp
now for for all of you that you have
never heard that class that class has
the following
property
yes if i give you a solution you can
check in polynomial time
that this is
a solution for an instance of a problem
and there is a mathematical guarantee
that says that the the pro the that
problem
has a um
solution now
tfp okay
from the theoretical computer science
perspective it is an interesting class
why because it has many interesting
problems like finding a local
in an objective function computing nasa
equilibrium games
factorization the collision of one has
functions but i was wondering why a
really different p class is a trendy
class and we want to find out why the
the simple items work
on this kind of problems from my
perspective the real answer is the
following because the humans
as algorithmic designers really like
sorry
trying to find solutions in problems
that they know that a priori there
exists a solution in that problem so
um
for the rest
of the discussion let's start with the
most basic ml task the most basic ml
task that i know is the following let's
find the minimizer of a function and
just to destroy a fallacy that people
have
finding
the optimal even in a convex function in
a convex body can be arbitrarily hard
for example it is np hard
to find the
global optimum of a convex function in
the compositive programming
and if i can make it even more
restricted
it can be
indecidable given that they cannot give
you a function that the solution
the optimal solution is irrational
number so how typically we relax that
first of all typically we ask not about
exact solutions but about epsilon
approximate solutions and the second
thing that we apply as a relaxation in
order to make the problem um feasible is
the the fact that we are asking
typically a local solution now the first
question that you can ask is okay we
relax the problem did we relax a lot
uh is the relaxation meaningful the real
question
that i am asking here is the following
let's imagine that this is the objective
function that we want to minimize
uh what we want to see is that
our function is more like that that
means that a local minimum has similar
performance with the global
meaning of the function and it is not
like that where the difference of the
local optimum in the global optimum is
uh
really big uh
okay now
good news let's say some good news here
uh
from machine learning perspective there
are lots of work of rangier ct
michael jordan that proves that the
majority of the machine learning tasks
that we know
the objective functions
the local optimum are non-spurious
spurious are the local opening of that
case um
so now the next question that you can
ask is okay can you explain a little bit
what is what does it mean locality uh
what does it mean neighborhood and
here is a moment that i will do a
separation
from the combinatorial local
optimization like the people that like
sat for example
what is a local optimum i will call a
flip k local
optimum
let's take the the max up that i give
you closes and you want to optimize
the
gain that you have from the from those
clauses uh you we call a flip k local
maximum
an assignment where even if you change
at most k of the variables you will
never achieve to go
better in your objective this is for the
combinatorial case now for the
continuous case uh it is something that
you maybe you remember from the calculus
uh what you need actually is the that
the local area the local geometry is
convex
this is expressed by this
condition and you want of course to be a
stationary point this is the first
condition
okay now
again from complexity perspective these
problems are
more or less hard uh even
trying to find the flip k1 local max for
the max up is pls complete and
there is a celebrated result some years
ago
about the
continuous
version of the problem that an absolute
stationary point
and generally the kkt
optimal points are cls complete that was
i think the best paper of stock some
years ago
so the question now okay
oh yeah yeah
so the real question here is uh
how do we tackle this problem in
practice
actually it is just one algorithm we
start by a candidate solution and
we check around our neighborhood and if
we find a better solution we we go to
that solution and actually this is what
gradient descent
is doing with the and grading just shows
the steepest
choice
now
from the complexity perspective this
algorithm is awful
pls completely says that there is always
an exponential
runtime
hard instance
and
there is again a result that says that
for grading descent method uh
the what you can see is that there are
instances of small functions that
you will have exponential time
but in practice
what it happens is that yes
combinatorial optimization works that is
the reason that we can
um
in the
airplanes can
go down to the earth
because we are solving a sub problem uh
during their traffic planning and i
think that they i have not to convince
you that the training of neural nets is
working well nowadays
so
what is the problem with the worst case
analysis the real problem is that worst
case analysis to myopic
we
sort out an algorithm or a problem based
on the brittle situation of the hard
distances while
the it would be the case that the
general instance of the problem is easy
uh
now how we can relax the worst case
analysis
uh
there are many different models okay if
the worst case analysis is good then we
are happy i mean in the worst case we
are good so
what can be in the best case
in the average case is a nice kind of
analysis but
then i needed justification about how
you randomize your input
so spiruman and tank
propose the modulus mode complexity
for those that you have never seen that
that means that i will apply the worst
case analysis but every time that you
will give me the input
i will perturb first in order to somehow
sample from the neighborhood of the
brittle
worst case point
and
i hope that in the best case i will
explain
the success of an algorithm because the
smooth version of
the landscape of the runtime would be
like that a similar situation holds also
about where you will converge
this is a question that typically we ask
in optimization so those are some of the
questions that i am interested in uh
with my advisor we discussed about the
um
the
flip the the
binary csps problems like max cut
like a max to shot
hamiltonianizing models
and we have similar results about
the case of
the continuous optimization
uh
i will stop here that i will just give
you some extra questions that i i'm
interested in right now what is
happening when you flip not just one
note but you flip more than one nodes
and
the the question is if we can extend our
analysis broader than just uh
the max 2 sat if we can make it in the
max
cases thank you very much
we have time for a quick question
can you say something about the higher k
just very briefly i mean
right now we have achieved to solve the
problem for the case of to flip
yeah it's a big use to go to from one
flip to flip
we're ready to discuss about that but
the real question is that one
the issue
is the following uh
okay let me er in two phrases how smooth
analysis works more or less it is a
potential argument what you say is is
that at every step at every step every
jump in every flip that you have
you have high probability to see a lower
bound
of some improvement so with
a guaranteed lower bound
you know that after a polynomial time
with high probability you will achieve
to
convert to a solution now the issue with
the max kcsps is the following
that it is much more complicated to
prove
every flip
uh influence all the other all the other
csps so
uh
flips that you believed that gives an
improvement very quickly can be proven
in the next rounds that
right now are worse
uh so this is the real difficulty that
someone has to tackle for the general
case
it is a very interesting open problem
for me and
for anyone that would like to work on it
i am happy to discuss with you
can you repeat again
this is about the continuous version
well the one where you introduce k-flip
or the gate
here you mean yeah
does this work by uh it's actually with
the elite and rachel name
where we can you can you go to the
microphone uh there is a work on
correlated instances where you have like
a csb instance okay and uh
you have a whole bunch of csp instances
actually that are given to you and you
know that the answer
a
for for all of them all of them have
answers
uh
and we know that the answers are
correlated to each other via this kind
of uh
flipping
so if you take the answer to one you do
some flips in a sense that's not exactly
but
i think it translates that you do some
flips
then also
each one of them can be answered by some
flipped version
and uh
if you're given all these instances
without the solutions but you know that
the solution has this correlation
then you can solve in palm real time oh
so maybe it's interesting to look at
yeah
first of all thank you very much i
wasn't aware about the the result no i
don't know
it might be related yeah yeah
it's because it's all about taking
statistics about the answer for each
location oh so you say maybe there is
like what smooth analysis gives you that
you you collect the somehow the
neighborhood but you have a an extra
assumption in that if somebody gave you
a bunch of correlated instances i see i
see and uh i wonder if that help if you
can imagine analyzing that i said
situation is an input right there's a
simple correlation
so the correlation model you could come
up with your own models but this
particular model is that if you take the
solution
uh and you flip each uh uh
by certain amount but even a small
amount or a large amount so one minus
what i am thinking from your sentence is
the following that
the correlation that you described is
combinatorial right
the correlation that it is described by
the
statistical uh that i'm just collecting
different instances but somehow
uh
it is very interesting i wanted to check
the paper uh
the one sentence that probably i can say
is
the first thing that i would like to see
is when i collect instances around
uh
that it is like the input i'm taking the
input here no because if i could collect
instances then i have a funnel time
algorithm but i don't the point is that
it's given so if i
somehow at least in places where it's
interesting you can't collect it because
it gives you a much faster algorithm
than we usually know so the the the
what you get the strength from is that
somebody somehow is given like why is it
a reasonable assumption somebody's given
you know the intuition is that we say
that then no i no instances that we care
about really isolate the exist in nature
that we all often
uh there's a lot of instances which are
kind of related to each other and
conjecture here is that they're related
through the solution space
and we never really invent any you know
the problems out there they're all kind
of perturbations of each other so why
not take advantage of the fact that we
have all those problems and and the
solutions are related and maybe this way
we can find so we can define a bigger
problem maybe where the solution is
unique or something that might be at the
community i i promise that i will check
the paper and i hope
next year i will be two years here next
year i hope that they will have an
answer
yeah we'll take you up on that now so
okay uh thanks to all the speakers of
the session uh we have a short break now
and we'll reconvene at 11 30. thank you
oh